Super Smash Brothers ultimate may look
similar to the Wii U version but there
are a lot of changes under the hood if
you want to be at the top of your game
you might want to familiarize yourself
with some of these changes and
strategies we're gonna start with the
basic tactics and end on the advanced
ones the whole point of Super Smash
Brothers is to knock your opponent off
the stage before he or she knocks you
off the stage unfortunately there will
be times when you get knocked off first
and will have to recover most characters
have a jump and then a double jump as
well as a special move that will get
them a little bit more distance however
this special move varies from character
to character for example link can use a
sword to spin like a helicopter and Ness
can use his PK Thunder to send them
flying in any direction some characters
might have a really good stage recovery
like Kirby and Pitt while others such as
in sinner or or Little Mac have terrible
recoveries some characters even have
multiple specials that can be used for
stage recovery Ike for example can use
the side special to recover a lot of
horizontal ground as you play around
with different characters make sure you
get a feeling for how each of their
recovery Styles work
[Music]
for most characters smash texts are
their most powerful moves smash attacks
can be performed by pressing a and
inputting a direction at the same time
alternatively you can also use the right
stick to use these moves you can charge
these attacks to inflict higher damage
but be careful though most of these
moves have a lengthy recovery time and
are pretty easy to dodge
the final smashes have all been
rebalanced thank goodness there are no
longer any final smash attacks that
allow you to transform into a
super-powered character for a limited
time and instead most of the final
smashes require you to be within arm's
length of your victim you really want to
wait for the right time before using
mamie fighters like Ike kromm Marth king
K rool and Peach are equipped with a
countermove
if you time the special maneuver
correctly you will counter another
fighters attack and deal a nice bit of
damage back at them practice this enough
and you'll find that successfully
countering an opponent is also one of
the most satisfying experiences in the
game
once again you can spot dodge roll and
air dodge however they work a little bit
differently in ultimate for starters you
can now perform directional air dodges
by inputting a direction with the dodge
you can even shift momentum with the
directional air dodge however there is a
lengthy recovery window so keep that in
mind you can perform a roll by inputting
right or left with the shield button
like in previous games this is a good
way to get on the other side of your
opponent encounter however if you roll
too many times in succession your
recovery will take longer and if your
timing is off this could leave you open
to a devastating smash attack spot
dodging occurs when you input down in a
shield and this grants you a few frames
of invulnerability these can be pretty
tricky at a time however if you
successfully spot dodge you can easily
counter your opponent from what we can
tell spot dodging multiple times in a
row doesn't seem to have any negative
effects learning how the dodge correctly
is key to Super Smash Brothers and it's
no different in ultimate learning which
dodge to use and when takes a lot of
practice but it can give you a
significant advantage against tougher
opponents
performing short hop attacks in previous
smash games always required a bit of
dexterity luckily in ultimate you can
actually press attack and jump at the
same time to do a short hop attack this
is useful because you can use it to
change up your standard - attack and
because it's a short hop you won't spend
that much time in the air as you build
up damage you might notice that your
character will start to smoke and flash
red this means that they are enraged
while enraged you deal more damage and
hit your opponent's harder rage can also
be used to close the damage gap between
you and your opponent if one exists for
the most part shielding works similarly
to pass smash games while on the ground
you can throw up your shield and it will
protect you from all incoming attacks
but over time your shield will shrink
and eventually it will break and when it
does break you won't be able to attack
or move for a period of time one big
change with shielding however is how
perfect shielding works if you drop your
shield right before an attack connects
with you the attacker will be stunned
momentarily the duration of the stun
differs depending on the strength of the
attack and if done correctly you can
follow up your opponent's attack with
one of your own getting the timing down
this is pretty tough so we'd recommend
jumping into training like right here
and set the CPU behavior to side smash
if you perform a perfect shield
correctly your character will flash
so those are just a few tips for super
smash brothers ultimate if you want to
get really good at ultimate we'd
recommend turning off items and playing
on battlefield or final destination map
variants this will allow you to focus
solely on the mechanics instead of
chasing down the best items or dodging
stage obstacles if you have more
techniques that you want to share feel
free to drop them in the comments below
and thanks for watching
[Music]